[Music]
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
there is a cinematic quality to the
music it's a pretty epic score this
movie being set in 1994 allowed us to
establish a different sound
the group that reflected the
environments and the cultures of the
characters Stevie wanted these being
very special so he asked Toby and wege
who plays reek in our film for Toby to
actually do a song
masterful collaboration seeing him live
in performance I was like how can we
capture that energy and the Transformers
film ain't nobody out here hard to kill
it again
it was really a phenomenal opportunity I
just couldn't believe it it was a great
pleasure to have not only Steven but
also Toby in the studio here with us to
really hear what we did I can't wait for
people to check it out
baby
Transformers rise of the beasts
that was a huge fan of Transformers as a
kid I was very influenced by what was
done in the past to create the
Transformers that we see today Steven's
creativity is phenomenal he's got really
inventive and fresh ideas and he's
bringing a totally different sensibility
to this movie
is about the fate of all living things
is it the first time the maximals are
ever seen in live action he wanted to
make sure everything was as authentic as
possible I'm not the one to fear Prime
the story takes place in the 90s and so
we work really hard to capture that era
everything from the type of music we're
playing the clothes that Noah and Elena
are wearing and when it came to Casting
Anthony Ramos a Dominique Fishback
recall from Brooklyn they brought their
own authentic brooklynite attitude that
just really pops on screen you brought a
human here I'm nobody I ain't even seen
nothing I'm not even seeing anything
right now
on this film we need to do something
different so we found unique locations
that showcase the size and scope of this
story
shot on top of Machu Picchu so that was
a real challenge
stepping on set with Stephen and seeing
his vision it's been amazing working
with Stephen it's all about humanity and
all about Hearts maybe there's a way to
save our home I've never had more fun
than I've had with Steven and Still's
confidence and he really is Sensational
let them come
y'all know it take the wheel
[Music]
foreign